la vie super compliquée il y a le
travail il y a les tragets le patron qui
est pas
content le manque
d'argent le copain qui sé tiraé avec les
sous que tu
prêté et puis et le temps
mauvais mais rien de rien de tout cela
ne compte plus lorsque tu
[Musique]
as un enfant
malade un
gosse en
danger
pourre
camarade die
[Musique]
désemparé ses yeux te
regarde
comme comme si te
disis nos
[Musique]
voyages
jouer le travail on s'en fout bien
l'argent ne sert plus à rien la pendule
est arrêtée le monde est bloqué ton
ménage qui craquait je vois soudain
rouder l'univers s'est fait
petit autour de son
lit car rien de rien de tout
cela
ne compte plus lorsque tu
[Musique]
as ton
enfant
mal ton
gosse en
danger
pour
camade tu es
demparé
ton
enfant
malade ton
gosse en
danger ta vie tagit
camarade
tu tu la
[Musique]
donnerai mais quand tu sais l'enfant
sauvé alors là tu te met
à
[Musique]
pleur